[Music]
everyone my name is Raja droppeth and
I'm a product specialist for the Android
platform here at Google Play today I'm
gonna begin our session by talking about
the Android Go opportunity and walking
through some details about the product
since we last spoke about it I'm then
gonna invite my colleague Steve to come
up on stage and walk you through some of
the data that we're seeing to support
all the details as to why we built go
including reasons why you should keep
your app small after that we'll have em
read come up on stage to walk through
all the requirements that you should pay
attention to when it comes to optimizing
your app and your game for these devices
and finally I'm gonna have James come up
on stage and he's gonna walk you through
all the details that we've been doing on
the Play Store to make sure that we're
delivering a really awesome store
experience for users on these devices so
to start things off Android Go was an
ecosystem wide effort to make sure that
we delivered an premium hardware and
software experience for users on
entry-level devices now in all of the
user research that we did globally we
found that users had very specific pain
points on these types of devices those
items included processor speed and
quality storage capacity and battery
life no matter where we went in the
world in developed markets in developing
markets users consistently can be coming
up with those issues on these types of
devices so we challenged ourselves along
with our OEM partners to deliver a much
more integrated and better experience at
this device capability it's important to
remember that Android Go is not a fork
of Android what we did was we actually
introduced a build time flag into the
platform that ensures that all devices
that are one gigabyte of lesser RAM
going forward are going to be go
configuration devices we worked with all
of our Google teams internally from
search to the assistant to YouTube and
maps to make sure that we delivered a
first-class Google experience as well
to users who are on these devices we
also made sure to introduce preload
limits we definitely don't want to have
users unboxing super slow phones the
second they buy them let's dive a little
bit more into storage performance and
security now again referencing that user
research that we were talking about
earlier we noticed that over two thirds
of users on devices with a gigabytes of
flash or less really only had about a
gigabyte of storage when it came down to
it you can't really do much with a gig
of space it's 2018 I want to take
pictures I want to download apps I want
to play games what we realized was we
needed to do a better job of actually
making sure that users had more storage
out of the gate and what we we were able
to accomplish with a software
improvements was that users now have 2x
more storage right off the bat that's an
additional thousand photos that they can
take on their phone now it would be
disingenuous of me to come up here and
ask all of you to optimize your apps and
your games for these devices if we
didn't ourselves actually do the same
thing so we got together with all the
different product teams for some of the
major apps that you know and love like
search the assistant Gmail YouTube and
made sure that we delivered a really
good experience from Google on these
particular devices some of our product
teams decided to remove some features
others decided to add specific features
for these two types of devices
it really just depended on the use case
for those particular teams one of our
most popular apps is actually files go
and in that scenario we realized that we
needed to deliver a better job for users
in terms of managing space on their
phones
we've been really excited to see some of
the the prot the the ratings and the the
excitement that users have with these
particular apps now security is at the
heart of everything that we do at
Android and one of the things that we
launched as part of this was Google Play
protect with the rise of peer-to-peer
sharing and offline the usage of apps we
wanted to make sure that users felt very
comfortable with the apps and the games
that they were downloading onto their
phone think of play protect as a badge
of trust
that essentially extends the play brand
to let a user know that the app or the
game that they're putting on their phone
can be trusted to be used on that
particular phone my colleague James will
go through more details about what that
actually looks like on a user experience
for these devices now I'm really proud
of all the work that we've accomplished
so far over the past year but let's take
a second to dive a little bit more into
the opportunity around why it matters
for you to optimize your specific
experience for these types of devices
this chart right here shows 2017
shipments globally for Android devices
broken down by the the RAM on those
devices as you'll see on the top right
there about 25% of global shipments
every year our devices that have one
gigabyte of less a ram sorry one
gigabyte of ram or less that represents
about 300 million devices in the market
currently now we expect the number to
actually increase throughout the year
but it just kind of gives you a general
sense for how many devices you should
expect will actually have this
configuration going forward we've seen a
ton of interest in the market from all
of our OEM partners in fact back at
Mobile World Congress in March we had
about six OMS launch devices I'm happy
to report now we have over 80 m80 OEM
partners committed to delivering devices
with hundreds more in the pipeline by
the end of the year we really cannot
thank our partners enough for all the
work that they've done to partner with
us to deliver a really awesome hardware
experience for entry-level devices I
definitely encourage you to go out and
buy a device just you can feel and see
just how premium the experiences at such
a decent price point now I want to dive
a little bit more into the Indian market
specifically India represents the
largest market for these types of
devices we expect about 30 to 35 million
devices by the end of this year that'll
have the go configuration on them
the the marketing that you're seeing
right here is what Micromax is actually
using in market to show users just how
premium the experience is and the good
thing to call out is that with carrier
subsidies many of these devices are
actually under 40 US dollars in these
markets so very very good price point
and still a premium quality hardware of
course
India does represent the largest
opportunity for these devices but I
can't stress this point enough the u.s.
is the second largest market for these
devices today every time I tell that to
people everyone looks at me with blank
stares because it doesn't make any sense
well the numbers prove out that there's
the US is the second largest market for
entry-level devices today this isn't
just a developing market problem or an
emerging market problem this is a
developed Western market first world
market problem as well users around the
world at these price points and at these
device configurations want to have a
premium experience and go delivers that
I'd like to now invite my colleague
Steve to come up on stage to walk you
through some of the data that we're
seeing on the play side around all the
information that we see that supports
the reasons why you should invest in the
opportunity as well all right thanks Raj
hi everyone my name's Steve I'm a
product manager on the Google Play
console so Raj just introduced you to
Android go it talks a little bit about
all the work that we've been doing to
shrink the storage and memory footprint
of our Google Apps in preparation for it
I want to talk to you a little bit about
the importance of doing your bit and the
rewards you'll get to your business and
your user relationships by focusing on
shrinking your app size and thinking
small now if you haven't gotten enough
data analysis over the last few days
hold on to your hats because I'm gonna
show you a bunch of graphs so as devices
have gotten more and more advanced
developers like you are making
increasing use of their capabilities
which is great it means you're packing
in more features than ever before you're
making better user experiences providing
providing more value to users but it can
come at Aesir
is cost this chart here that I'm showing
and you might have seen it earlier shows
the average app size served on Google
Play over the last 10 years and you can
see very clearly the app size has
continued to increase in fact it's grown
250 percent over the last five years
alone and it's still growing all that
increase in size may be materially
impacting your user acquisition strategy
app size has a very real effect on
conversion rates and the successful
download of your app this chart shows
the correlation between app size and
user conversion rates specifically when
I'm talking about conversions I'm
talking about users who come to the Play
Store and tap install that's the
conversion we're talking about here
clearly the heavier your app you can see
app size as the x-axis the less likely a
user will be to install your app even
when we account for things like store
listing optimizations size has a very
clear negative impact on whether or not
a user will want to install your app on
their device in fact the data shows that
for every 6 megabytes that increases on
an app size we see a decrease in the
user conversion rate of roughly 1% that
trend applies to all apps under a
hundred megabytes and it also applies
globally that's a material loss and
conversion that could be recovered if
you focused on app size but that's not
all we can also compare a country by
country now if we compare the percentage
increase in conversions by reducing app
size by 10 megabytes we first of all see
by the global average that worldwide
users see more benefit they tend to
install more but this can vary
dramatically country by country as well
shrinking your app by 10 megabytes in a
country like India or Brazil has a
larger impact on your store conversion
rates than countries like Germany the
USA or Japan but if you look across all
emerging markets the removal of 10
megabytes from an app size roughly
correlates with an increase in
conversion rate by about 2.5 percent
that's pretty big but let's see let's
drill down a little bit farther
when we talk about businesses we talk
about conversion rates but we have a
different lens that you might not have
seen before because we're also the ones
that serve the apps so what happens
after a user taps install well they
still have to download the app right so
we can also measure what percentage of
apps by size and actually fully make it
to the device you have a hundred percent
transfer rate and are ready for install
and that's what this graph shows here so
you can see that as app size increases
the success of a download it drops
precipitously now this could be for a
variety of reasons that aren't all shown
here so for example it might be for
environmental conditions perhaps in
certain parts of the world network
quality isn't as high as we would like
it to be it's not as reliable as we
would like it to be it might also be for
user actions
perhaps the user gets tired of waiting
around for a large app to download or
maybe once they're on the download
screen they see just how large the app
is and they decide to cancel the blue
line here shows apps
excuse me devices that have less than or
equal to one gigabyte of RAM which is
the same device profile as the Android
go devices we're talking about and you
can see that the impact is even more
dramatic for those sorts of devices but
whatever the individual reason the
action you can take today is clear keep
your app small in many parts of the
world users pay attention to app size
when deciding what to download this
chart shows the median download size
country by country for devices with less
than or equal to one gigabyte of RAM so
in countries with cheap data or cheap
storage or strong network reliability we
see that users have a natural tendency
to prefer larger apps which you can see
in the blue but in many markets
particularly across Africa and Asia we
see a clear trend towards smaller apps
but just read reiterate Rogers point
this isn't just an emerging market
problem if we look at that median
download size again we can see that the
u.s. is roughly right in the middle of
our global minimum in our global maximum
so this implies that roughly 50% of
users
the US and countries like it also are
more likely to prefer smaller apps the
u.s. is the second largest market for
Android Go devices globally and I think
these numbers sort of help to support
that statement so you might be saying to
yourself what's the point of this part
of the presentation is Google really
trying to tell me to remove features
from my app and and try and make my app
small by doing that not exactly what I'm
trying to do is paint for you a larger
picture of the decisions and the factors
that you should weigh when considering
what to do in your app next some of your
decisions my Ally might cause you to
lose out on quality installs and prevent
users from installing your app I'm now
going to pass it to my colleague Amrit
who will dive more into the details of
how to optimize your app for Android go
thanks thanks Steve anomalous ng I'm a
developer advocate at Google based in
India and in this session I want to talk
about how you can optimize your apps to
make them Android Go ready what we've
learnt working with our partners is that
when they actually optimize their apps
for Android go it just did not benefit
only the users who used Android Go
devices it did help everyone who was
using their apps it worked with people
who are in emerge markets as well as
using high end devices as you'll
hopefully see tuning these apps with
these requirements will enable all your
users and will bring a lot of benefits
for you let's walk through some of the
technical requirements here firstly you
need to set your target SDK to 26 or
above this will not only ensure that you
deliver the latest Android experience to
users it will also allow you to comply
with a Play policy change that requires
you to set the target SDK to n minus-1
API level where n is the latest Android
API if you're targeting a version lower
right now you need to ensure that you
test your apps thoroughly to make sure
that there are no breakages or
functionality changes because of this
API change there are some behavior
changes
we are 26 and you need to account for
that limitations like background
processing location updates notification
edges are some of the examples of
regions where you might want to test
more thoroughly the second requirement
is reduced the apk size for apps we
require you to make it less than 40 MB
and for games that's extended to 65 MB
that's excluding the secondary downloads
when I say 40 MB that's kind of the
upper limit that I'm talking about here
you didn't make it as small as possible
here are some of the things that you
could do in order to reduce your apk
size firstly remove all unnecessary code
on unnecessary libraries that you have
added into your build ensure that the
libraries that you're adding are mobile
optimized and not server-side once the
drawables in your resource folder they
need to be optimized for both size as
well as for formats if you got if you're
looking for backward compatibility and
you're adding support v4 modules ensure
that you're adding only the modules that
are required by the application that and
not all of them in case your app has
audio resource files like dot wav files
try converting them to mp3 or AAC which
are much smaller formats thereby
reducing the apk size but it's not only
about changing these things you also
need to measure them right so if you're
using a traditional apk format you need
you can use the android apk analyzer
that shipped along with android studio
to check the sizes of the APK and also
compare your apk against the previous
one as you make changes to see how well
you're making increments in this one if
you're using the new app bundle for mac
then you might want to use the bundle
tool and check the size of the splits
here we all know that entry level
devices the RAM constraint so you need
to check all your key use of features to
ensure that they run properly without
any issues on a Phi 12 MB RAM device en
are janky frames out of memory
exceptions are things that you got to
watch out for so test your apps
thoroughly before you release them for
these problems and fix them proactively
for you send it out in the market once
you've actually put it out there in the
market you need to observe and
reactively fix issues as they come
Android White Rose which James will
actually talk about later on firebase
crash lytx and firebase performance
monitoring tool are some of the SDKs
that you could use in order to do this
reactive part really really well let's
take a look at the requirement for RAM
usage start a memory in your apps should
be less than 50 MB and for games that's
extended to 150 MB I want to make clear
that what when I'm talking about RAM
usage I'm talking about the proportional
set size here or PSS in short PSS is
basically the sum of the private memory
your app is using plus the proportion of
the shared memory with other processes
tests all your key user journeys and
optimize them for memory usage and make
the memory footprint as low as possible
a common way to find this PSS number is
to use the Magnum foe command that you
run from the adb shell or you could use
a debug memory class and
programmatically calculate this let's
move on to app startup time here
the requirement here is that apps would
start in less than 5 seconds but I mean
startup time in 5 seconds what I mean is
be fully interactive in less than 5
seconds we all know that quick starts
are key to avoid early on installs an
abandonment a quick startup time is key
in building a perception that your app
loads fast and it's fast for the user as
a general rule you need to ensure that
your app is perceived to be fast on
these devices
in order to measure the app startup time
you could use the firebase performance
monitoring SDK which actually calculates
it automatically and shows it on the
firebase console for you we're extremely
proud of the work our partners have done
in order to reduce size and improve
performance for their for their users we
can't thank them enough for partnering
with us on this initiative and in
providing a fast performant and rich
experience for their users I'm gonna now
show
you a video that our team has put
together highlighting the experience
Flipkart team had while they were
optimizing their app for Android go
let's take a look
Flipkart is India's leading e-commerce
player its mission statement has always
been how do we enhance the living
experience the lifestyle of Indian users
by bringing the most affordable and most
quality products to all sections of the
country using technology one of the
biggest learning from our user base was
lot of these devices were actually with
less than 1gb of RAM where people were
actually aborting their journey because
the phone could not handle the storage
or the computation requirements so we
don't start Android Co application if I
can load my pages faster I can give
those additional milliseconds back to
the user which can actually give the
user a much better experience in their
shopping journey on Flipkart the app
installs size as per the Android Go
guidelines needs to be less than 40 MB
and with some good guidance from the
Google team we have brought that down we
are using a notice to do refactor and
ProGuard so which is helpful for
reducing the sources and code base apart
from that we are also using WebP II
which is giving us 20% reduction they
may download size the guideline that we
received was the proportional set size
should be less than 50 MB so we did a
lot of resource allocation changes in
our core base we reduce our memory cache
size from to a screen to 0.5 screen we
reduce our bitmap pool cache size from
40 screen to 1 screen working on the
Android Go app for Flipkart our app has
become much lighter it has become more
performant the existing user base we've
actually seen the uninstall rates go
down by 34 percent our latest app
versions now crash almost 10 times less
as compared to our older versions with
an average trading of 4.4 plus a lot of
effort has gone behind reaching that
milestone we are excited with Android Co
that will be crossing the 200 million
very very easy and very very soon
because we believe
next set of online users are actually
going to come on devices for which
Android Go is the right medium to
approach so if you're an app developer
and if you are building for India just
go get out understand your user try to
make your technology tailor to those
needs and then you would have an app
which will be loved by your users we're
so proud of the work Flipkart and all
our partners have done in order to
optimize their apps for android go I
would like that now I'm gonna now hand
over the stage to my colleague japes who
is going to talk to you talk to you
about the Play updates thank you thank
you hey everyone I'm James and I'm a
product manager on Google Play I work on
initiatives like Android Go the emerging
markets and end user optimizations and
I'm really excited to share all the work
that the entire play team has put in
over the past couple of years to do
lower quality Android experience to our
users let's dive into the work we're
doing in the store I'm gonna chat a
little bit about end user experience and
then optimizations and improvements we
made under the hood and then I'll tell
you guys about some of the tools that
we've developed for you to make it
easier to build on Android go a key
point that I want to make today is that
there is no go version of the Play Store
it's just the Play Store optimized for
go it's the same Play Store on every
device we did this deliberately because
we think that the optimizations that we
can make should be the customer should
be able to take advantages of those
optimizations on any device that they
may be on whether it be a go device or a
pixel we aren't limiting the catalog on
Android go so users get access to any
title that you choose to distribute to
them whether your distribution settings
be limited by location or by device type
so we kind of need to set the example
you've heard today over and over that
small matters we went out over the past
year and have more
chopped the Playstore in half from a
size perspective and we're now just at
or below 10 megabytes on all devices
globally it's an accomplishment I'm
super proud of users and emerging
markets have made it ultra clear to us
that mobile data is their currency so we
ran a couple of tests and we showed how
expensive any app download is on a card
and on search results and as you could
imagine users opt for smaller apps even
if a rating may be lower so in a couple
of places we actually replace where we
previously had apk an app rating with an
app size we found that showing the apk
size increases install rates and more
importantly user engagement over time
remember what Steve said earlier apk
size does have an effect on install
conversion and successful install rate
and with the OP with the rise of offline
and peer-to-peer sharing Play wanted to
ensure the users could still trust the
apps and games that they got from us no
matter where those apps came from that's
why we introduced Play protect you can
think of it as a badge of security that
users will know and trust so what this
does is it gives users device it gives
users on any device type confidence that
there have a safe and secure app
experience when they're interacting with
these apps in the context of play how
did we do it we wanted to make sure that
an app can be trusted on a user's device
so we started to attach a very small bit
of security metadata to every app and
game that we publish then what we can do
is if a user acquires an app offline we
or via peer-to-peer we can use play
protect to deter to read that security
metadata and determine an apps
authenticity and verify its source you
as a developer get the added benefit of
being able to service those apps because
we will bring them into the users play
library and will be able to update those
apps in the future
there's a major pain point that we know
you've relayed to us we're excited to
address moving forward apk size the
downstream metrics that come from it
installs how long a user may keep an app
on their device and apk size getting
bigger over the past 10 years caused us
to really take a step back and evaluate
ourselves and we said what can we do to
make this situation better well through
that analysis we came up with Google
Play dynamic delivery today you can use
Android app bono Android app bundle to
benefit from a smaller app without
needing to refactor your code the app
bundle also enables future
modularization what it does is it
reduces your app at the moment the user
installs the app it allows you to load
dynamic feature modules on demand at the
point when they're needed further down
the road when the user is engaging with
the app rather than making sure there's
lots of pressure at install time the
Android app bundle along with Google
Play dynamic app delivery ensure we
deliver apps of the future that are
modular instant and dynamic we've also
tuned the Play stores personalization
algorithm to show smaller apps on lower
level devices and as you could imagine
this increases engagement because
downloads are more successful and
smaller apps run better on these
entry-level devices this is evident and
all the data we've collected on user
behavior and it's key to think about how
size will affect App Store ranking for
these users we've done a bunch of
feature improvements for the store for
example when a device or when a user is
near device disk capacity space we
suggest to users removing apps that have
either never been opened or haven't been
used in a long time you can see on the
screen here we show a mock of apps that
are of a specific size that haven't been
used from least frequently used to most
frequently use and we give the user
who's trying to install your app an
opportunity to delete in
app that a stale or they or they've
never used and that gives them an
opportunity to have a better experience
with your app another thing that we
recognized we were not serving our users
in the best way was the notion that a
lot of users manage app installs when
they're on Wi-Fi well we thought we
could do better so we created plays wait
for Wi-Fi feature it's a known usage
pattern everyone sees all the time
but we thought play could do a better
job of particular V this particular user
need data management is important to
these users so if today if a user is on
play via a mobile connection they can
either when they hit install they can
either choose to install that app
immediately or delay that download until
their device connects to Wi-Fi and will
initiate the download in the background
and alert them when when the download
and install is complete this gives users
more control it saves metered data and
most importantly it saves money we also
took a look at ourselves and realize
that we weren't doing a very good job
from an offline or a connectivity
tolerance point of view so we built a
couple of additional features the first
one is when the Play Store is on Wi-Fi
we cache a larger percentage of the most
visited parts of the store so what that
means is is if the user turns mobile
data off or their connectivity is crummy
or their connectivity is spotty we can
actually serve a greater percentage of
the store directly from cache this is
great because it works offline it's also
great because it's a super fast
experience for our users then when they
reach the edge of the cache they're
offline and they can't bring up any
additional pages we've built another
feature that allows the user to opt into
a notification that will bring them back
to that part of the store that they left
once their device establishes a
connection again this is a great
opportunity for the user to get back to
play to download your app all the
features I just walked through are
designed to give end-users a
high-quality store experience but I also
want to
that we have tools available for you to
help you optimize your app for these
Android Go devices in these markets
the first which you which no one in this
room should be unfamiliar with is
android vitals android vitals gives you
an insight into ANR's and crashes and
it's in its paramount for understanding
stability of your app battery and the
most important part is that android
vitals performance impacts your promote
ability on the Play Store especially in
the context of search and discovery we
also introduced a flag as Raj previously
spoke of called is low ram that allows
you to adjust your apps UX and
distribution choices we want you to
optimize for maximum distribution here's
an additional tool to help with that
we've also included details about
Android Go devices in the console
pre-launch report this allows you to
check on your builds and understand how
they're performing on actual Android Go
devices on testbeds before you release
the market be sure you incorporate a
regular cadence with the console
pre-launch report as part of your normal
QA and release management process so you
guys have been to a lot of meetings
you've heard a lot of things and if
you've been on your phone the last 25
minutes the four things you need to
remember Android Go is a huge
opportunity
keep your apps small play is doing
everything you can to improve or excuse
me
you should do everything you can to
improve app quality by loving leveraging
the Android tools and play plays
delivering a focused experience for
these users thank you everyone
if you have any questions the four of us
will be up here at the front looking
forward to hearing from you
[Music]
[Applause]